[Musique]
mieux dans le débat sur france 24 c'est
sans doute l'image du jour emmanuel
macron à kiev accompagnée de la vache
folle ces de mario draghi aux côtés de
volodymyr zelensky trois chefs d'état et
de gouvernement qui sont arrivés ce
matin de pologne dans la capitale
ukrainienne après un voyage effectué en
train ils ont été rejoints par le
président roumain klaus iohannis ce et
c'est un message d'unité européenne qui
a été adressée aux ukrainiens quatre
chefs d'état et de gouvernement qui se
sont dits favorables un statut de
candidat immédiat de l'ukraine à une
adhésion à l'union européenne emmanuel
macron a annoncé également la livraison
de six canons caesar supplémentaires à
kiev qui s'ajoutent aux 12 déjà livrés
et il appelle aussi la russie accepté
que l'onu organise l'exportation des
céréales ce qui nécessiterait bien sûr
la levée du blocus par moscou moscou a
réagi le kremlin a jugé futile les
livraisons d'armes occidental à
l'ukraine le cren alors est-ce qu'elle
va obtenir effectivement ce statut de
candidat immédiat à l'union européenne
quel est l'impact de cette visite macron
draghi shaul sur le conflit le cren
bientôt européenne on en débat avec mes
invités j'ai le plaisir d'avoir à mes
côtés pascal joulain bonsoir directrice
générale de la fondation robert schuman
et puis avec ce rapport ce rapport
schuman sur l'europe états de l'union
2022 qui vient de paraître aux éditions
marie b est bienvenu dans le débat en
face de vous à la lazare eva bonsoir
rédactrice en chef adjoint de
l'hebdomadaire ghi ukrainian week
bienvenue à vous alberto toscano est
avec nous journaliste écrivain italien
auteur de ti amo francia de léonard de
vinci à pierre cardin ces italiens qui
ont fait la france bien voir ce à vos
godasses et en face de vous pascal
boniface bonsoir bieber fondateur de
l'institut des relations internationales
et stratégiques iris coauteur de la
géopolitique tout simplement et c'est
aux éditions eyrolles avant de débattre
vous propose tout de suite d'écoutés
emmanuel macron et le président
ukrainien s'était donc lors de cette
conférence de presse qui a eu lieu il ya
quelques instants à kiev tous les quatre
nous soutenons le statut de candidat
immédiat à l'adhésion à l'union
européenne pour l'ukraine nous aurons
dans les prochains jours à bâtir
ensemble
l'unanimité des 27 pour ce conseil
européen si important
mais à travers
notre visite les échanges que nous avons
eus cette expression claire c'est un
geste fort rapide attendue
d'espoir et de clarté que nous voulons
envoyer à l'ukraine pays est prête à
faire tout le nécessaire pour devenir
membre la plainte titre de l'union
européenne et toute la population tout
le peuple ukrainien ils aspirent
nous avons vu les sondages qui montrent
que la plupart la majorité des
populations européennes soutient cette
perspective d'intégration européen
delecray nous avons un niveau
historique de soutien
parce qu'elle vous fasse juste pour
cadrer d'abord le débat qu'est ce qu'on
peut dire de l'image de ces quatre
présidents européens et ils chefs d'état
chefs de gouvernement qui arrive à kiev
il était temps a dit ce matin le
président du sénat gérard larcher est ce
que c'est une sorte de visite de
rattrapage alors oui saplv vécu comme ça
puisqu'on attendait beaucoup que trauma
conviennent à kiev il avait un peu
attendu c'est vrai que j'en aurais eu
tant il ya des élections présidentielles
il y avait un délai qui est le 30 juin
le 30 juin puisqu'il ne sera plus
président du conseil l'union européenne
et donc il a voulu marquer un peu unités
des trois pays qui sont apparemment les
plus réticents à un soutien total à
l'ukraine si loin comme cela que s'est
présenté en ukraine
l'allemagne la france sont très
fortement critiquée en ukraine pour
l'être pour avoir eu des relations dans
le passé avec la russie et d'italie est
également sous cela et donc il ya
toujours une volonté effectivement de la
part de ces trois chefs d'état de dire
non non nous seuls quelques rennais ceci
étant ça ne suffira pas l'ukraine
préféra toujours les états unis aux pays
européens et je crains que tous les
gestes qu'ils soient faits en faveur de
l'ukraine actuellement notamment
le fait de dire que dès maintenant
l'ukraine peut être candidate à l'union
européenne l'ukraine va l'empêcher mais
ça ne va pas changer la perception qu à
l'ukraine de ce qu'on appelle la vieille
europe les pays qui sont les plus
anciennes nations européennes et ont
rejoint un peu la division qu'il y avait
pendant la guerre d'irak en 2003 où est
ce que c'est une un peu une victoire
tout de même pour d'immerger linski
cette visite on a vu ces images je pense
pas que c'est une victoire mais c'est
vrai que emmanuel macron était très
attendu attendu en ukraine et que le
sucre et une accorde beaucoup
d'importance de visite de président
français c'est vrai qu'il y avait
certaines réticences mais descellant je
n'irais pas jusqu'à dire que le crâne
préfère les états unis onu union
européenne déjà géographiquement on ne
peut pas on peut pas devenir le 50
premiers états les états unis on cherche
pas le faire par contre lyon 2
européennes c'est logique et disons ça
s'impose par là notre histoire par notre
géographie par notre culture par notre
combat pour la liberté donc je crois que
vous vous mariez en chantant quelques
reviennent vous préférez l'europe tout à
fait réunies oui oui bah en fait je
préfère c'est à dire que je pense que on
a besoin de tous les alliés qu'on ne
peut avoir on est reconnaissant aux
européennes et aux américains à tous les
occidentaux qui nous soutient parce
qu'un jeune est ce que c'est un tournant
pour l'europe ce qui vient de se passer
est ce qu ont pas ou peu parlé d'une
procédure accélérée de candidature de
l'ukraine à l'union européenne alors ce
qui est certain c'est qu'il ya un
message d'unité qui a été volontairement
après c'est pas la france qui vient tout
seul c'est la france allemagne italie
donc trois pays fondateurs et le
président roumain rejoint voilà par le
président roumain par ce klaus iohannis
cela parce que ça veut dire qu'il y
avait aussi un chef d'état d'un pays
d'un nouvel état membre et donc que la
division est ouest qu on a pu sentir
avec la déclaration d' emmanuel macron
ce faux pas humilier là aussi l'aïe en
effet il ya un chef d'état d'un pays de
cette partie donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
un message d'unité européenne de
solidarité européenne on vient tous
ensemble du chrtr on vient à huit jours
du conseil européen ou en effet il
devrait y avoir une décision qui est
prise
sur la candidature qui a été déposée le
28 février donc quatre jours après la
guerre en russe par le cred par le trend
auprès de l'union européenne et en effet
pour cette partie là c'est à dire cette
candidature on a été très vite puisque
la commission européenne lors du premier
voyage de mam von der leyen au mois de
mars avait apporté le questionnaire que
l'ukraine qui a répondu assez rapidement
et que la commission européenne après
avoir fait un deuxième voyage la semaine
dernière va rendre sa conclusion ce
navire puisque c'est une procédure on
adhère à l'union donc c'est bien la
présidente de la commission qui va
rendre un avis demain un avis qu'on
propose qu'on suppose positif mais après
il ya cette réunion du conseil européen
l'aiac la semaine prochaine oui il ya
déjà quatre chefs d'état et de
gouvernement qui siège il ya deux chefs
d'état et de chef de gouvernement sur la
photo est dans sa fait 2 427 savoyard
mais bon là et donc eux ils disent on
est pour en effet la reconnaissance du
statut de candidat la ceinture la
reconnaissance du statut ce candidat
c'est pas ils deviennent membres de
l'union européenne samedi matin ou
dimanche matin c'est ils auront vocation
à rejoindre la famille européenne c'est
un signal politique très fort pour
l'ukraine qui depuis plusieurs années
comme vous l'avez dit se bat pour les
valeurs fondamentales et les valeurs
européennes et c'est aussi un signal
pour vladimir poutine en disant écoute
nous à l'europe on va en effet puisque
tu agressés ce pays on va le prendre
dans notre giron un jour pas tout de
suite et donc c'est en effet un moment
charnière puisque dans huit jours le
président va présider son dernier
conseil européen avant la fin de la
présence française émana vidéo qu'il
devrait y avoir une décision qui
pourrait aussi alors un d'un petit petit
peut-être aussi concerner la moldavie
alors justement on verra ça sera la
semaine prochaine alberto toscano alors
celui tout de même qui était le plus
favorable a en fait à cette adhésion les
ukrainiens à l'europe et qui en tout cas
depuis le début marque un engagement
assez clair du côté des ukrainiens c'est
mario draghi qui était donc avec olev
choc avec la chaussée tension est
effectivement beaucoup plus tendue oui
c'est vrai j'ai moi aussi j'ai remarqué
le fait que le chancelier détendu
pendant la conférence de presse nos
lecteurs à vous pensez qu'elle était
tendue aujourd'hui aussi oui vous les
conditions d'accord moi j'ai plutôt eu
chose aujourd'hui mais pour revenir à
terry draghi a sans doute une ligne très
rock américaine ça c'est clair et net
d'ailleurs on parle de lui comment
possible secrétaire général de l'otan à
l'avenir mais le gouvernement draguer
par contre n'est pas si unanime dans
cette ligne sans doute engagé du côté
ukrainienne et du côté américain et pour
ceux qui regardent leurs symboles
d'aujourd'hui moi je trouvais que
c'était un symbole formidable les 3 1
semble qu'ils ont manifesté surtout un
symbole de l'europe l'europe existe
l'europe envie de collaborer et même
ceux 10 heures 11 heures de voyage en
train ensemble en arrivant de pologne à
vinythai dans leur région en plus de
part et d'autre beaucoup de choses y
compris la difficulté des politiques
antérieures d'être très parce que bon
c'est qu'ils ont avancé landais de sais
pas si banal mcrae rally manuel da cruz
aujourd'hui dans dix mois je sais pas
c'est mario draghi sera le mario draghi
d'aujourd'hui et car olivier
changer les choses je sais pas si lui
même sait qui est sûre les chasser les
soldes c'est à dire s'il a vraiment une
ligne politique de ce gouvernement qui a
encore en train de commencer à faire ses
preuves je lirai l'effet draghi il y a
eu un grand cédric la présence de drague
était important aussi parce qu'ils sont
expérience des ex présidents gouverneur
de la banque centrale européenne sans
doute est utile à cette nouvelle
gouvernance politique européenne ceci
dit pour ceux qui regardent la
candidature de la crème moi je crois que
sans doute en l'europe acceptera que
l'ukraine sera officiellement candidate
manque être officiellement candidate est
entrée dans l'europe il y a beaucoup
la turquie est candidat depuis combien
de temps
donc je connais le chemin qui amènera
l'ukraine à l'intérêt de l'union
européenne sera beaucoup plus difficile
de ce qu'on croit aujourd'hui pascal
boniface est ce que justement cette
visite va faire pression sur les plus
réfractaires des pays européens je pense
par exemple pays bas au danemark ou
encore à l'autriche qui eux sont plutôt
réticents demande d'abord des
préconditions des préconditions sur
l'état de droit sur la corruption des
conditions qui vont devoir négocier avec
la messe est dite sereine accepter enfin
les listes c'est une réponse
émotionnelle à un problème stratégique
je veux dire on n'a pas regardé la copie
de l'ukraine on a dit oui parce que vous
souffrez parce que vous êtes agressé
parce que des crimes de guerre sont
commis contre vous et donc il faut qu'on
envoie un message est donc on gelard on
fait vraiment une procédure d'urgence
par rapport aux situations d'urgence
mais il n'y a aucun examen leur bien sûr
ça peut être ils ont une façon un peu
hypocrite de relayer les choses pour
plus tard je suis pour l'instant pour
montrer une solidarité ont dit ok on va
accepter votre candidature mais en fait
l'ukraine n'est en rien prête à adhérer
à l'union européenne
donc il y avait d'un prêt de vie
économique d'un point de vue de la
gouvernance du point de vue de la
gestion donc même s'ils ont tout faire
dans l'urgence ça sera quand même très
difficile donc en fait il faudra voir si
on continue de réagir de façon purement
émotionnel et que même la procédure
d'adhésion et précipité on va dire on va
payer je comprends que les polonais ou
les pays-bas lé soient pressés parce que
c'est pas eux qui vont payer
ce sont la france l'allemagne l'italie
les autres pays qui vont payer donc pour
eux c'est pas très grave a compris un
terme à ce que je bois pascal des
politiques agricoles comme un
juste juste à la juste bonne réaction
après ce qu'a dit pascal beau visage ce
que vous avez pas peur qu'on fasse
miroiter à l'ukraine une entrée dans
l'europe et finalement ça va prendre 15
ans 20 ans est-ce que l'ukraine va
pouvoir s'adapter alors qu'effectivement
c'est un pays en guerre aujourd'hui est
ce que vous n'avez pas peur de cela qu
effectivement il ya un symbole mais que
tout ça va prendre très longtemps on n'a
pas peur de rien notre peur à brûler
pendant cette guerre sous les
bombardements de russe a au contraire on
ne sait très bien qu'on n'est pas prêt
pour l'instant économiquement
politiquement juridiquement on est prête
à travailler on a fait déjà un énorme
chemin à partir de 2014 quand il y avait
le premier aydan pour justement
rejoindre le chemin européenne et on est
prêtes a duré tout le chemin et faire
tout le travail nécessaire pour une fois
qu'on est prêt à rejoindre la famille
européenne pour vous c'est vraiment
important dort entre dans l'union
européenne c'est naturel voilà j'ai
culture m nous sommes heureux peine
parce que nous sommes une peuple
européenne en pleine paix m gr on est
historiquement culturellement au pav
linguistiquement tout ce que vous voulez
on est européen on n'est rien d'autre
vous y voyez une forme de protection
face à la russie aussi mais surtout au
bail a que nous qui pouvons nous
protéger en fait on a besoin d'armes
certes on a besoin d' aide économique
mais il ya que notre armée qui peut nous
protéger vraiment parce qu'elle joue
alors justement il y en a qui disent ça
deviendrait le quatrième le pays en
termes de population il absorbera une
partie justement des fonds réservés aux
agriculteurs c'est ce que disent tous
les réfractaires à l'entrée justement de
l'ukraine au sein de l'union européenne
alors bon moi j'aimerais ça fait
vraiment il y aura 1 et la procédure
pour la reconnaissance de ce candidat
parce que en effet il ya cette situation
de politique et c'est cette agression
maintenant j'ai pas compris que après ça
allez sa traque salaires je crois que le
président de la république dans ce qu'il
a dit a dit qu'on allait donner un
message avec une feuille de route il y
avait un message également à l'intention
des balkans occidentaux qui sont
candidats et qui sont des petits pays
justement il de la serbie et le rôle de
vie et donc c'est assez mais c'est une
réflexion qu'on doit avoir sur en effet
c'est le lait l'europe étant le plus
petit continent on a en effet devant
nous des pays des pays c'est l'union
européenne c'est un état s'était pas un
état c'est une union de d'état donc en
effet on a des pays et donc qu'est ce
qu'on fait pour agrandir tout ça il va
falloir peut-être un peu de temps pour
que je sois en mesure de remplir les
critères que nous avons déjà fixés et
qu'il va falloir qu'ils remplissent on
commencera par l'échappée plus difficile
la lutte contre la corruption etc n'a
pas révélé plus facile mais enfin que
nous aussi à l'intérieur on fasse aussi
des efforts vais peut-être un travail
pour faire accepter à nos populations
consacrant dit et que le club de l'union
européenne puissent travailler quand il
serait bien mais on serait 35 à
l'intérieur une population ils sont
elles prêtes justement non par un papa
papa mon ce pas être plus de 27 alors
aussi aussi aussi on sait si on parle
aux pubs et les siens ont bien entendu
l'ukraine aujourd'hui un mouvement 2
comme vous l'avez dit émotion alors donc
on accueille les réfugiés etc on est
prêt à le faire mais bien entendu à un
moment t qui va être dans 10 ans minimum
il faudra se donner rendez-vous je
rappelle qu'en france pour toute
nouvelle adhésion il faut où la majorité
des tiers du parlement où un référendum
donc qu'est donc donc fait donc il a
fait le chemin est très long ben le
schéma est très longtemps n'a jamais dit
que ce serait facile mais on leur donne
aujourd'hui l'assurance qu'ils ne seront
pas tout seul et c'est aussi un message
pour vladimir poutine on leur dit en lui
disant voilà bah tu arrêtes tu as réussi
à provoquer quelque chose qu'on aurait
peut-être pas imaginé faire dans quatre
mois alors le chemin est très long
ça mais c'est surtout je rejoins pascal
c'est la question de symbole parce qu'on
n'est pas obsédé par l'idée de faire
partie de l'organisation internationale
obligatoirement donc c'est ce qu'une
porte ans oui et avoir une assurance
d'appartenance à la famille européenne
se connaît déjà et pouvoir vivre notre
vie
faire nos réformes développer notre
langue notre culture notre identité et
rester dans nos frontières donc c'est ça
aussi de frontières internationalement
reconnues c'est ça ce que très important
pour nous après le chemin vers l'union
européenne elle prendra le temps qu'il
prendra là c'est c'est pas l'objectif
numéro 1 l'objectif numéro un c'est la
l'intégrité territoriale alberto toscano
effectivement est ce que l'europe a les
moyens c'est ça d'absorber un pays comme
l'ukraine ou tous les autres la moldavie
les moyens et 6 547 déjà à leur hôtel
existe des formules différentes l'europe
à mon traître capable dans les moments
de besoin d'imaginer des schémas à
géométrie variable ce que le président
m'a cran a dit lors de ce matériau la
presse régionale n'ont pas plus devant
être imposée comme inutile robert
si on veut trouver un solution on la
trouve l'entrée à plein titre de
l'ukraine mais aussi de la serbie qui
est candidate officiellement l'union
européenne et d'autres pays encore sans
doute serait un problème aussi pour
cette question de la france parce que la
france est l'un des obstacles principaux
parce que la france ayant obligé
pratiquement 1 choisir sa part
référendum elle se trouverait dans un
contexte où il y aurait pratiquement à
inferno sur l'une est là l'opinion
publique française la reconnaît et on
connaît aussi des inquiétudes sur la
politique agricole commune et son
élargissement et enfin les problèmes en
france serait très sérieux mais aussi
dans d'autres pays la géorgie ainsi
qu'ils voulaient rejoindre l'union
européenne il faut trouver une façon
pour lancer ce message de paix parce que
ce message avec l'ukraine est un message
de paix d'ailleurs il faut les laisser
des messages de paix au civa la russie
qui est aussi un pays européen le peuple
russe est un peuple européen
la tragédie que nous sommes en train de
vivre c'est qu'on est dans une guerre
civile et robert et cette dimension des
deux peuples européens qui s'entretuent
nous fait terriblement du mois en tout
cas il va y avoir déjà une aide pascal
boniface financière de l'europe
indépendamment même de cette candidature
avaya déjà une importance assez normal
un pays qui souffre qui est en guerre
qu'il ya une aide effectivement c'est la
moindre des choses l'accueil des
réfugiés il ya une aide militaire
guenned économique donc ceci a été
décidée il n'y a pas d' envoi direct de
militaires mais on participe quand même
beaucoup à l'effort et la france a quand
même les entreprises françaises ont
renoncé à 7 milliards d'actifs en russie
parce que on l'est on les a sommés de ne
plus être présent en russie c'est quand
même pas rien comme contribution
également donc il ya effectivement une
une aide multiforme qui a accordé à
l'ukraine mais je pense qu'on mélange un
peu les choses entre la solidarité avec
un pays qui a agressé qui en l'état de
légitime défense et l'accès à l'union
européenne a bien sûr on peut dire
effectivement quelque part il ya une
sorte de tour de passe passe puisque la
candidature ne vont pas adhésion et que
bon mais voilà tout ceci fait quand même
de la mauvaise politique puisque on est
dans les 2000 vérité et le sun en aurait
pas de père autrement pascal sinon le
message aurait été dramatique vis-à-vis
des ukrainiens qui souffrent et
vis-à-vis de poutine au pouvoir au nez
il y avait il y avait quelque chose qui
nous obligeons pascal
e.on et dans les faux semblants on est
dans les symboles on est pas on n'a pas
été déçu on est vraiment dans la
politique d'un bord à long terme des uns
des autres et latéral interne mais
valoir le travaillé pendant plusieurs
années pour qu'on puisse aussi nous
avoir cette possibilité de faire adhérer
les gens qui veulent adhérer parce que
sinon je vais enfin il ferait tout fort
quel est notre intérêt du divertissement
qui a été trop rapide trop lent et la
fatigue pourtant c'était là si rapide
par exemple la roumanie louis me disant
je t'aime
rapide bar en face a été trop rapide par
rapport à l'élargissement à l'est c'est
devenu un faiblir l'europe et il ne vous
arrive pas échappé qu'il ya quand même
une fatigue ou des réticences vis-à-vis
de l'europe de la part des anciens
membres parce que l'élargissement était
vécu comme ayant été trop rapide mal
défini et ses dents plutôt à l'émotion
qu'à l'analyse rationnelle des intérêts
une réaction peut être à la caméra laser
eva rivas pardon veille afin de se ses
oui je pense qu'on ne parle maintenant
beaucoup de valeur matérielle je veux
parler des malheurs avant de valeur
morale parce que c'est les ukrainiens
qui est mort pour la liberté pour la
fraternité aujourd'hui et pas les
français les italiens et les autres
vieilles nations donc je suis désolé de
le souligner ma série noire dont vous
êtes dans l'émotion ce qui est normal on
n'est pas fait mention on est dans la
vie et de la mort tout à fait autre
chose et donc ancien étudiant je
réagirais comme vous bien sûr si on ne
parle de valeurs aussi matérielle c'est
la russie qui doit payer les
répartitions répression s'est pas
l'europe c'est la russie qui doit payer
tout ce qu'il a cassé il doit respecter
tous qu'il abolisse europe 1 bah
pourquoi quand elle perdra la guerre il
va tout payer tout ce qu'il doit vous
allez aller à moscou pour exiger que la
russie paye on aura quatre non non mais
je veux dire une personne n'ira moscou
pour faire payer la russie donc on voit
bien que le coût énorme de
reconstruction le reprendra sa part et
c'est principalement l'europe qui paiera
parce que je doute que la russie paye
quoi que ce soit là on peut peut-être
éventuellement ce qui serait pas une
mauvaise chose se servir sur les biens
des oligarques qui ont été gelés mais
entre gelé des biens et s'en saisir ya
une nuance et n'est pas sûr qu'on puisse
la franchir mais c'est l'europe en
grande partie qui va payer la
reconstruction de l'ukraine réaction des
rustauds de la marianne à une
aujourd'hui puisque le kremlin a jugé
futile
livraison d'armes occidental à l'ukraine
je cite un futile dmitri peskov donc a
dit lui espérer qu'ils donc macron
draghi est chose exhorteront le
président de l'asc y avoir une approche
réaliste de la situation qu'est ce que
ça veut dire parce que je joue à la
maison on sait très bien que les russes
sont pas contents d'abord ils sont pas
contentes de deux choses ils sont pas
contents qu'on s'en mêle
est-ce qu il ne méprise pas un peu les
européens lorsqu'ils disent est ce que
finalement vous ne sont pas contents
qu'ils s'emmêlent est ce que les nazis
niasse et finalement ne souhaite
rencontrer ou en tout cas neutre à ne
faire des tractations qu'avec joe biden
ah non alors ça ça sent il ne peut pas
faire que cette rotation avec joe biden
et en europe il alors c'est pas un
secret qu en effet la russie n'a jamais
vraiment compris et accepté que cette
europe qui estime avoir sauvé en partie
soit unie et soit forte parce que ce qui
est aujourd'hui la réalité c'est que le
petit continent européen soit plus fort
économiquement et commercialement que la
russie c'est la réalité le pib de la
russie c celui de l'espagne
donc un seul alors à 27 on est largement
au dessus donc c'est quelque part pour
eux un truc qu'ils ont jamais pu alors
ils ont divisé l'europe autant qu'ils
pouvaient aujourd'hui mais entendu
l'ukraine ils voudraient qu'on ne s'en
mêle pas mais on va s'en mêler et on
s'emmêle d'autant plus qu' il ya quand
même un état qui arrive à parler à
vladimir poutine c'est le français je
vous rappelle pour deux choses non
seulement parce qu'il préside le conseil
de l'union européenne aujourd'hui même
si c'est un état nucléaire et que sa
nette à faire maintenant le seul état de
l'union européenne membres permanents du
conseil de sécurité on aura deviné c'est
d'ailleurs ça qui donne un statut que
n'ont pas ni el sol et ni draghi et
c'est pour ça que c'est bien que la
france avec ce ticket qui est multiple
et soit venu avec deux autres anciens
états membres de l'union européenne
fondateur et le romain et je trouve que
ce symbole là aussi c'est un symbole de
l'europe qui essaye d'exister on a
beaucoup reproché de choses alors s'il
essaie d'exister un peu de manière
stratégique un peu de militaires et que
cette guerre en du caire réveille en
effet le laxisme qu'on a eue sur ces
questions et qu'on prenne des décisions
qu'on n'a pas prise parce qu'on était
dans un confort tranquille sur deux
oreilles au réalisme et ben c'est pas
mal je ne dis pas qu'il faut qu'on
devienne puissance militaire mais si on
est un peu plus fort on sera respectée
par nos adversaires pour en revenir à la
réaction des russes alberto toscano
lorsque kremlin dit qu'il juge futile
livraisons d'armes occidental à
l'ukraine une façon de mépriser disons
les entrées en temps utile et futile il
y a qu une nuance
de futile et inutile mais peut-être de
gagner parce que ces armes sont utiles
et elles le sont certainement à leur
cause non je crois au delà de la boutade
que les russes et c'est comme pascal
disait d'ailleurs de nous mettre à
l'épreuve et de voir jusqu'où cette
europe qui a petit pêcheur qui est en
train de payer très cher les sanctions
la russie chose que le sucre indien
devrait voir et est respectée peut-être
parce que nous faisons déjà aujourd'hui
de gros sacrifices et je ne sais pas
qu'est-ce qui se passera à l'automne
parce que les contrecoups de cette
situation de cette crise économique et
nous vivons et qui succède immédiatement
un christ de toute autre nature provoqué
par le co lead et peuvent déclencher des
réactions en termes tout d'abord d'
infractions difficile à contrôler et
ensuite de mouvements sociaux dans nos
pays dont on vit nous mêmes une
situation difficile le besoin de trouver
une sortie de cette crise de cette
guerre provoquée évidemment par
l'agression russe sur ce n ya pas de
doute mais le besoin de trouver un seul
chemin pour sortir de cette crise m jour
après jour plus nécessaire de tout point
de vue à commencer par le moral
justement à l'ordre mais aussi par le
point de pascal boniface à ce que la
réaction des russes pour être au
contraire plus virulente après une telle
visite ou est ce qu'elle est
indifférente ou non à défendre le fait
que les russes disent que c'est futile
prouve que ça les embête beaucoup une
façon de dire même pas peur mais en fait
ils sont très gênés par le fait que les
européens et sur une plus large échelle
les américains fournissent une
assistance militaire l'ukraine sans
laquelle elle est russe aurait atteint
10 aux utilitaires beaucoup plus
lointain là ils sont quand même même si
dans le donbass il continue à avancer on
voit bien qu'ils n'iront pas tellement
plus loin parce qu'ils n'ont pas les
moyens et que l'ukraine à la fois par la
mobilisation par le sursaut national et
par l'aide étrangère donc par ce mélange
de mobilisation patriotique très forte
hélas une matériel étrangères ont pu
stopper l'avancée et faire reculer la ou
les russes avaient avancé est donc le
problème c'est de savoir quel est le
compromis possible entre l'ukraine et la
russie aujourd'hui et le comprendre
quels compromis territorial est possible
les ukrainiens 10 et là on voit qu'il ya
des scénarios très différents l'esg rien
dit il faut qu'on récupère l'intégrité
territoriale certains avant le 24
février mais certains disent y compris
la crimée ce qui à mon avis quand même
est relativement disons peu réalisable
et je ne suis pas sûr que militairement
les forces l'ukrainienne soit en force
suffisante y compris avec l'aide
militaire étrangère pour déloger les
russes d'où ils sont et les russes
veulent aussi une victoire donc est ce
qu'il ya un compromis possible c'est
vrai que toute conquête territoriale
pour les russes depuis le 24 février
c'est un gain pour l'agresseur puisque
effectivement c'est bien la russie et
donc il est difficile de donner une
prime à l'agresseur mais le problème est
dans la mesure où il a été très clair
copains coquins pays occidental ne
fournira une aide militaire humaine
autre que matériel à l'ukraine je ne
suis pas sûr je ne suis pas sûr que
militairement il soit possible de
déloger l'armée russe du lombard alors
ça arrive à moi je pense que c'est
possible et qu est la victoire dès le
crâne va venir je sais pas quand je sais
pas par quels moyens mais c'est ce que
se passe maintenant c'est la guerre de
colonisation elle dure depuis plusieurs
siècles il est là les épisodes plus
sanglant moins sanglant mais que le cren
retrouvera sa liberté y reviendra à la
maison en europe un jour ça il ya aucune
doute après les moyens d'ouvrir le
moyenne c'est une question 13 m très
important c'est à dire des armes des
arbres oui des armes des armes lourdes
dont l'examen manque beaucoup et si on
avait plus vite et en plus grande
quantité on pourrait beaucoup plus vite
délogé les russes et les faire un projet
pour l'instant ce n'est pas le cas pas
le cas parce que dans ces armes lourdes
qui sont de plus en plus techniques et
aussi besoin que l'armée ukrainienne
soient formés soit formé public et non
césar on en a donné 12 rien accession
est libre et on va en livrer dix huit au
total je crois que c'est parti d'un
accord que le président français le
président heinz qui ont voté mais que ce
sera suffisant encore une fois c'est ça
la casse pour l'instant on voit qu'on
voit quand même que c'est c'est à cette
c'était d'ukraine et très résistantes et
très engagé et c est moi je veux pas je
vais pas dire deux choses mais on a
quand même perdu l'alsace et la moselle
en dans une guerre il en a essayé de la
récupérer parce qu'il y avait pas de
raison que cette intégrité territoriale
ne la récupère pas et on l'a récupéré 50
ans après alors je ne sais pas quand
l'ukraine récupération territoire et je
vois pas comment on est ils ne se
battront pas jusqu'au bout pour
récupérer sur exactement voyez je suis
donc il n'y a pas de fenêtre pour
l'instant d'opportunités pour une
discussion pour une négociation comme a
pu le présenter par les locaux d'un
débat à commercer ces territoires ça
c'est clair et simple pour nous c'est
absolument impossible si on ne parle
excusez moi si on ne parle des compromis
c'est tôt de parler parce que les
combats continuent les combats sont
féroces les gens se défend vraiment au
maximum de leurs forces et tant que
c'est c'est la situation sur le champ de
combat qui va définir en fait ils nous
on n'est pas encore en position de
négocier c'est cette eau et bientôt
c'est vrai qu'avec les frontières de
l'ue crème corrigez moi si je me trompe
on était changé pendant la période de
l'union soviétique et et en particulier
pour celui regard de la crise et donc
la nation et crème je crois c'est une
chose les frontières actuelles ne sont
pas forcément des frontières historiques
le crès oui il ajouté reconnu
internationalement dans le mémorandum de
bus d'allemandes et d'allemands
et que la russie a signé donc maintenant
logement international fmi a été fait et
on s'assoit dessus aussi la parole du
droit international on peut la déchirer
parce que cette plaie à monsieur poutine
delà des chiffres il faut lui rappeler
que est tout état doit respecter et
je ne fais pas un discours purement
juridique je fais pas j'ai fait un
discours de bon sens sur les chemins de
recherche indispensable de la paix et du
dialogue dont est pour dire que les
critères de l'avenir de du découpage de
ce qu'il ya à l'est
malheureusement étant dans certains cas
incertain peut laisser des mages à la
négociation au bon sens et au contraire
mais à quel prix alberto toscano l'aï vu
c'est au prix d'un compromis existe
toujours donc bah ils parlent
d'intégrité territoriale en ukraine et
dans les îles des bases c'est le droit
international le droit international
doit être respectée selon le droit
international 1991 le crâne une fois
qu'il a retrouvé son indépendance il se
retrouvait dans les frontières internet
doit être occupé par un tiers de son
territoire la turquie selon les douanes
la semaine c'est un pays de l'union
européenne là qu'est ce que tu réponds
parce que là on a apporté on a importé
un problème qu'on n'a pas réglé dupuis
de l'adhésion à l'union européenne bien
d'autres voilà qu'aujourd'hui pour ça
que pour la pour l'ukraine ça prendra du
temps mais on peut pas les laisser sur
le bord de la route et on veut pas dire
négocier à tout prix parce que ça nous
arrange
pascal lagoutte et enfin on peut on
imposera pas le crâne de négocier non ce
sont les ukrainiens qui négocieront
quand ils voudront mais la guerre
continue donc effectivement le dilemme
pour l'ukraine c'est accepter au moins
demain zaleski était prêt à dire ont
négocié doute hudon à cesser le feu et
on parlera plus tard du dombass et de la
crimée là une fois enlacés un peu changé
et donc pour l'instant en fait le
problème c'est que chacun russes et
ukrainiens
je ne mets pas sur le dans le même sac
un agresseur et agressé mais chacun
pense que il y a encore une victoire
militaire qui est possible et donc le
cessez le feu n'est pas possible parce
que chacun pense obtenu une victoire
militaire moi je comprend effectivement
que l'ukraine veuille récupérer son
territoire parce qu' aucun pays ne veut
céder une part d'histoire nous mêmes la
france effectivement
voulons récupérer des as et la lorraine
simplement je doute je ne suis pas
certain que matériellement militairement
il soit possible à court terme de
chasser l'armée russe d'une en basse
sans une implication occidentale qui
suffirait la troisième guerre mondiale
dans laquelle nous voulons pas lui c'est
ça le problème ce sont les lignes rouges
qui évoque finalement pascal boniface
dans l'aide à l'ukraine mon énergie dans
les traits de voir voilà la troisième
guerre mondiale en certaines séances se
passent déjà parce que la france qui dit
non non pas on ne fait pas la guerre
effectivement militairement où il n'y a
pas d'armé français sur notre terre
bayalan française il ya aussi les
solutionner aucune troupes occidentales
qui va aller en soi même mais il ya les
sanctions qui sont acérés quand même
important et donc on peut pas il ya
aussi la guerre d'information il ya la
france qui était agressé plusieurs fois
par la russie pendant les campagnes
électorales la campagne précédente
d'emmanuel maquereau ou la voyez que
durer combien de ton seigneur bah je ne
je ne suis pas voyante donc je pouvais
pas vous dire mais je sais que on va se
battre jusqu'à fin ça c'est sûr qu'on
est très déterminé et qu'on
pense que c'est absolument
amoral immoral de céder à la russie
parce que le monde où l'art civique
gagnera contre l'ukraine ce sera le
moment absolument une fréquentable le
monde où il ya le droit du plus fort
quelqu'un qui a le band nucléaire il
peut imposer ses règles il peut voler
les territoires il peut violer les
enfants il peut enlever les gens il peut
les kidnappés par les centaines des
milliers et tout ça parce qu'elle a une
bôme claire et parce qu'il le veut et
parce qu'elle a décidé qu'elle va plus
reconnaître les frontières qu'elle est
reconnue il ya 20 ans mais on ne peut
pas vivre dans le monde comme ça nous on
ne veut pas et je vous invite dans le
monde pareil alors la visite justement
de ce fameux trio max pons draghi schulz
a démarré aujourd'hui pascal boniface je
sais vous devez nous quitte et allez-y
vous avez un rendez vous urgent merci
d'avoir été avec nous il nous reste
encore une petite dizaine de minutes
pour parler justement du début de cette
visite ils sont allés haïr pin donc la
banlieue la banlieue de kiev avec le
ministre de la décentralisation
ukrainien qui leur a montré bien sûr les
destructions de cette ville une ville
qui est devenu une sorte de symbole une
ville martyre on va écouter d'ailleurs
mario draghi
ils ont détruit des garderies des
terrains de jeux et tout sera
reconstruit ils ont déjà commencé
on sait que les crimes de guerre donc il
ya des enquêtes qui sont très
importantes que tim craignant
manifestement emmanuel macron a annoncé
qu'il allait qui va ya voir qui allait y
avoir une fourniture prochaine d'un
laboratoire mobile dbz analyses adn il a
dit d'ailleurs le président français il
faut lutter contre toute forme
d'impunité ce n'est pas hasard
effectivement alors que kiev se
multiplient les enquêtes contre les
crimes de guerre et là dessus les
ukrainiens sont très engagés tout à fait
il ya des leds justement des chars des
enquêteurs français qui sont venus sur
place des gendarmes de gendarmes aulas
donc il ya une grande dette de la france
au passage je profite pour remercier la
france pour ça et évidemment qu'on tient
de faire les jugements et le travail des
enquêteurs maintenant pour créer notre
dynamique qui se passe d'habitude
traditionnellement pendant la guerre que
ya d'abord la guerre après la fin de la
guerre et après seulement on commence à
inquiéter c'est trop tard donc on veut
aller tout de suite on veut que le monde
voit ce qui se passe chez nous justement
pascal boniface a mentionné zelensky qui
était plus ou moins prête à négocier
mais un mois de mars elle a changé la
vie justement rien changé d'avis après
que c'était découvert tous ces crimes de
guerre oury bâ et river les boutures
exactement parce que là on ne peut pas
pardonner on ne peut pas s'asseoir à
table avec les gens qui commise tel
crime équipes rendent pas les
responsabilités que les actions pas donc
ce n'est pas possible il faut qu'il
change le ton il faut que la situation
change est ce que j'aurai ce que
l'europe justement aide l'ukraine dans
ses enquêtes lorsque le procureur
crânienne c'est très active en union
européenne a fait beaucoup alors parce
que d'abord il ya eu tout de suite la
volonté d'aider il ya deux les deux
entités qui sont euros juste au niveau
européen et europol qui sont et qui ont
été associés il ya des conventions qui
ont été créés avec les ukrainiens et la
cour pénale internationale parce que
comme vous l'avez dit madame il faut en
effet pouvoir avoir ses preuves
maintenant que les existent pour pouvoir
s'en servir un jour un moment on pourra
en effet faire le procès mais au moins
avoir en effet toutes ces preuves pour
montrer que les autres pourront pas nier
et qui aura plus de deux heures a été
effacé donc ça il ya ce travail là qui
est fait l'union européenne paye pour ça
elle a pas d'enquêteurs en elle-même
mais elle paye pour ça et vous avez vu
d'ailleurs autour des présidents et
chefs d'état qui étaient là un nombre de
forces de sécurité impressionnant parce
que en effet on est dans une incertitude
la conférence de presse n'était pas dit
fait des dt pas de diffuser en direct
mais en différé il ya quand même
un risque que ces quatre personnalités
aient pu être à un moment donné a
inquiété dans leur voyage donc en effet
les mesures qui sont prises et l'union
européenne fait en sorte qu' on puisse
aider tout ce qu'on peut faire en
matière d' enquêtes en matière de
essayer de trouver des moyens de pouvoir
faire sortir les céréales par des moyens
terreur pour l'instant déclaration
là-dessus demandant la russie de lever
le blocus alors là dessus pas de réponse
de la russie va être très compliqué
c'est un peu dans la main entre les
mains des russes cette arme cette arme
céréalière mais aucun nom mais police
pour tout ce qui est de l'ukraine à ce
qui est dans l'ukraine puisqu'il ya on
parle vraiment on parle pas de la russie
là on parle de dé production ukrainienne
qui ne peuvent plus donc être exportée
via odessa pour parce qu'il ya un blocus
et si on n'avait pas bleu à lever le
blocus c'est que trouver des moyens de
le faire venir par la roumanie où les
pays qui ont une frontière terrestre
mais là se pose en effet des tas de
problèmes de logistique puisque les gros
travail est également fortement des
rails n'est pas le même il ya des
camions à mettre et c'est cette logique
elle peut être faite et l'europe va
payer pour essayer de faire en sorte que
les réserves ukrainienne de céréales qui
compte donc dans certains pays ont
besoin et c'est leur ferait aussi une
rentrée d'argent pour qu'en effet le
coût de la guerre qui est déjà énorme
pour les ukrainiens ne viennent pas
encore affaiblir l'économie ukrainienne
davantage qu'elle ne l'est alberto
toscano en tout cas pour cette séquence
qui a démarré à irbine l'idée c'était
vraiment de montrer aux dirigeants ses
quatre dirigeants européens l'horreur en
fait la barbarie c'est leur première
visite
le fait de vivre cette guerre au coeur
de l'europe c'est l'horreur et l'horreur
évidemment des massacres les crimes de
guerre tout ça tout ça est insupportable
et tout ça doit pousser à chercher le
chemin du dialogue
malgré tout la paix on a fait avec
l'ennemi avec l'ami et on choisit pas
son propre ennemi et le chemin de la
paix a toujours été difficile il était
de la guerre du vietnam
pour laquelle il n'y a jamais eu de
persécution pour crimes de guerre ont
cependant la guerre dilatoire médias
parlent de crime de guerre c'est un peu
bizarre qu'un sirop knicks mais à terme
écrivent ces jeunes il est certes un
procès pour crimes de guerre sur
malherbe malheureusement les procès
faits
contre aces mais qu'est ce que ça veut
dire que deux poids deux mesures pour la
passe et
bien évidemment on fait le procès du
chef de guerre contre le rwanda contre
les serbes en effet pas contre les
américains je crois que les français
aussi
bien sûr il faut le faire mais il faut
en même temps dire tout ça avec une
amertume qui vient du réalisme et c'est
seulement en prenant compte un garde à
deux pieds sur terre
sans rien enlever à la dimension
tragique de cette situation qu'on peut
malgré tout trouvé la force de faire des
sacrifices et pour se battre pour un
compromis alors là ça arrive à
une question pour terminer justement
demain la commission va prendre une
décision sur justement cette candidature
à l'union européenne la semaine
prochaine est ce que vous allez attendre
ce vote des vingt-sept manière
vous est anxieuse que ça fonctionne pas
je ne suis pas anxieuse de ma nature je
suis sereine et je pense que bon j'ai
confiance des gens nos partenaires
européennes je pense que le statut de
bon le chemin vers la verte vers le
statut de candidat va sans doute être
entamés ouvert bon après le chemin
inverse on ne sait très bien que ce sera
long mais non je suis pas inquiète
pascal je pense qu'aujourd'hui la messe
est dite comme disait
un peu plus prudente mais je pense qu'en
effet le président a montré aujourd'hui
qu'ils avaient une pierre qui avait été
mise dans ce dans cette dimension là je
crois que le présent et nas qui a aussi
et que donc tout cette tension qu'on
voyait monter entre le présent français
le président ukrainien est tombé et des
images fortes qui sont comme vous l'avez
dit haïr pin sans le présent et là ce
qui entre les chefs d'état 2 donc il ya
une solidarité action vision qu'on
voyait monter entre les anciens et les
nouveaux entre l'est et l'ouest est en
train et que donc le président de la
république la semaine prochaine va
essayer en tant que président du conseil
de trouver en effet le moyen d'avoir
avec lui derrière les 26 autres états
membres où même les 22,2 puisqu'on a
déjà il y aura un moment tous unis
auprès d ukraine sa maman il ya une
volonté de donner un signal c'est pas en
effet le début de ses débuts d'un grand
processus voilà ça clôt à ça clôt un
chapitre qui a été rapide mais qu un
processus qui va être non ou en effet je
pense là l'ukraine d'abord et la
moldavie vont pouvoir avoir en effet ce
ticket je suis un peu plus moins sûr que
la géorgie l'obtiennent dès samedi
prochain
le site que le chemin peut être que l'on
danse et la georgie dont peut le ranger
un tas parce que la situation n'est pas
la même il ya des d'autres difficultés
mais le la vie que donnera la commission
parce qu'elle donne qu'un avis
concernera les trois candidats mais
évidemment merci beaucoup d'avoir été
avec le basket johanna merci beaucoup
alberto toscano merci beaucoup à vous à
la halle hasard elle va merci à vous
tous d'avoir suivi merci bien sûr un
pascal boniface qui viennent nous
quitter a quitté ce plateau il ya
quelques minutes est resté avec nous sur
france 24 vous pouvez retrouver
l'émission sur le podcast et sur les
réseaux sociaux et sur notre site
internet
www.transat.com
[Musique]